[Musica]
[Applauso]
[Risate]
Chi sono i padroni dell'aria ho imparato
a riconoscere i padroni
dell'aria ascoltando e raccontando le
storie della mia terra ed è anche grazie
all'incontro con molti di loro che
stasera sono qui a a parlarvi
e il fatto di aver deciso di vivere in
questo territorio di vivere a Casella in
Pittari mi ha dato la possibilità di
incontrarne tanti e di
collezionarle tantissimi al anche
all'interno di questo video che stasera
vi
proietterà spesso i padroni dell'aria
vivono in luoghi marginali in comunità
marginali ma fanno la differenza nella
loro loro azione e nel loro agire
quotidiano come creatori di
senso vivono in luoghi che invecchiano
Ma che si rinnovano ciclicamente nel
nostro
Appennino in queste nostre comunità
nelle nostre famiglie nelle nostre
organizzazioni nelle imprese nelle quali
Viviamo e lavoriamo i padroni dell'aria
fanno la differenza e fanno la
differenza soprattutto quando
mettono in dialogo più generazioni tra
di
loro i racconti di una generazione
ispirano le generazioni che seguono e
così Impazzisco quando vedo ragazze e
ragazzi alla ricerca di padroni
dell'aria e alla ricerca di occhi
esperti magari racchiusi in rughe che
fanno da cornice a occhi che hanno
Sapienza hanno saggezza e che hanno
tanto da dare ai giovani
sono un filmmaker
e mi penso di più come un manovale delle
storie e sono nato con una
professionalmente con una videocamera in
mano e da quando una videocamera tra le
mani il mio cruccio è quello di
raccogliere storie raccogliere storie di
donne e di uomini che hanno qualcosa da
dare agli altri che sono e sono storie
quelle che raccolgo e quelle che
incontro che continuamente stimolano chi
le
Ascolta c'è una una caratteristica Anzi
ci sono due caratteristiche due varianti
che ho imparato a conoscere durante
questo percorso queste due varianti sono
i
giga che raccolgo durante questo
percorso quindi i gigabyte di
archiviazione delle storie e i
chilometri che percorro questo
territorio per chi ha voglia di
conoscerlo attraverso le storie passa
attraverso queste due varianti gigabyte
e chilometri andare incontro alle storie
per portarsele a casa Non stare fermi e
aspettare che le storie arrivino a noi
e questo approccio mi ha portato a
conoscere decine forse centinia di
padroni dell'aria
e ne vedete alcuni ma sono solo alcuni e
stasera proverò a raccontarvi Che cosa
si intende per padrone dell'aria o
meglio che cosa intendo io per padrone
dell'aria e cosa intendo dire quando
comunico e racconto questa provocazione
e soprattutto per lanciarvi un'ulteriore
provocazione perché così quando
incontrerete un padrone o Una padrona
dell'aria lo potrete
riconoscere spesso i padroni dell'aria
sono imprenditori artigiani
amministratori pubblici
designer però hanno qualcosa di più sono
persone che padroneggiano l'aria grazie
alla loro capacità di raccontare storie
di essere leader di essere dei
moltiplicatori di
opportunità quando si abita un luogo si
può essere padrone materiale di quel
luogo ma non padrone dell'aria i padroni
dell'aria Invece padroneggiano la
dei luoghi anche senza esserne padroni
materiali sono coloro che grazie alla
carica di carisma e di racconto che
portano con sé e che sprigionano quando
sono con gli altri riescono a aprire
mondi all'interno di quel luogo e far
sembrare una piazza un teatro
o un palco una straordinaria scena di
uno spettacolo
e
spesso dovremmo riflettere
quanto oltre a essere curatori dell'aria
dal punto di vista biologico e
fisiologico dovremmo curare l'aria che
contiene le storie che viviamo e questa
è una caratteristica che ho trovato nei
padroni dell'aria sono dei custodi delle
storie dei luoghi e questa è una delle
cose che dopo vi
racconterò nell'intraprendere
questo percorso o anche avuto la
possibilità di trovare persone che
custodiscono il patrimonio millenario di
luoghi che ci circondano Siamo
circondati da bellezza E pensate a tutta
questa bellezza senza le persone che
riescono a
sprigionarsi azioni
diverse quando si ritrovano L'una di
fronte all'altra sprigionano forza
all'interno dei luoghi in cui
vivono nei decenni scorsi abbiamo
immaginato e siamo caduti all'interno di
una narrazione che vede l'innovazione e
il progresso relegata soprattutto tra le
mani dei giovani spregiudicati e
accaniti verso qualcosa che ancora non
c'è questa narrazione è una narrazione
che in realtà non è sempre esistita
l'innovazione e il progresso nei secoli
scorsi appartenevano anche alle persone
vecchie agli anziani e una delle cose
sulle quali dovremmo riflettere è il
fatto che una società che veramente
innov innova e progredisce non esclude i
saggi dai processi di innovazione ma li
Integra all'interno dei processi di
progresso e di innovazione quindi
l'innovazione non appartiene solo ai
giovani ma appartiene all'incontro tra
le
generazioni imparare a padroneggiare
l'aria ci dà quindi un primo input
andare da chi è più saggio di noi da chi
è già padrone dell'aria
attingere non solo dalla conoscenza
enciclopedica ma dalla Sapienza Da
quegli occhi di cui parlavo prima
Sapienza fatta di pratiche fatta di
esperienza
fatta di cose che non stanno magari
scritte nei libri ma che stanno scritte
in quei gigabyte da raccogliere in
quelle storie da raccogliere grazie ai
chilometri da
percorrere Beh mio nonno è il mio
maestro dei padroni dell'aria Perché
quando lui è nei suoi luoi quei lui sono
diversi è lì che ho capito qualcosa in
più rispetto a questa a questo binomio
quando vedo mio nonno nei suoi luoghi
capisco che lui è il padrone dell'aria
di quei luoi ne padroneggia il
senso quindi i padroni dell'aria cosa
fanno creano senso attraverso la propria
opera attraverso la propria presenza
attraverso le proprie idee E attraverso
le connessioni che riescono a generare
quindi sono degli attivatori sociali
e ho maturato l'idea che le
organizzazioni e le imprese
e le comunità nelle quali
viviamo riescono a creare un impatto
veramente forte all'interno della realtà
in cui operano se sono costellate da
padroni
dell'aria adesso proverò
a raccontarvi Quali sono secondo me le
caratteristiche però questo è un
progetto in beta permanente non sono
delle caratteristiche chiuse Sono delle
caratteristiche aperte potete
aggiungerne di vostre nella vostra
ricerca innanzitutto i padroni dell'aria
attingono ad un insieme di simboli e di
segni finiti nel loro mondo e lo
combinano in maniera
infinita Se ci pensate è un po' come
facciamo con le 26 lettere dell'alfabeto
che sono un insieme finito Ma che ci
permettono di generare parole
potenzialmente infinite e a loro volta
di generare storie potenzialmente
infinite i padroni dell'aria prendono un
mucchio di simboli e di Segni e li
rendono infiniti nella loro
combinazione un'altra cosa che sanno
fare i padroni dell'aria è
innestare sono dei designer prendono una
pianta e fanno quello che per secoli
hanno fatto nella nostra civiltà
agropastorale appenninica i nostri
antenati hanno innestato migliaia di
piante per conservare biodiversità i
padroni dell'aria sono dei designer per
interpretano una pianta che è nella
terra e che è vigorosa e ci innestano
sopra una Marza con una visione la
visione di un nuovo frutto e i padroni
dell'aria fanno quello riescono a
innestare su qualcosa che c'è ma che non
dà i frutti
desiderati sfuttando quella forza vanno
avanti con una visione di innesto oggi
lo chiameremo
design quindi innestare vuol dire vedere
qualcosa di nuovo dove c'è già qualcosa
senza tagliare quella
pianta poi i padroni dell'aria sono
degli straordinari custodi di storie le
storie sono i dispositivi sociali per
eccellenza ci tengono insieme stasera
siamo insieme Grazie alle storie Siamo
qui per delle storie
e le storie sono nella loro
straordinaria potenza sono anche sia
contenitori che contenuto sono perimetri
che ci proteggono ma anche luoghi
sconfinati e questo i padroni dell'aria
Lo esercitano tutti i giorni usando le
storie a seconda di come
servono
un'altra delle caratteristiche dei
padroni dell'aria è come dicevo prima la
creazione di senso e come si crea il
senso all'interno delle nostre comunità
come lo come Lo esercitano i padroni
dell'aria il senso come lo tengono vivo
lo tengono vivo con rituali che sembrano
ancestrali Ma che si innestano su
pratiche Anche moderne su pratiche
contemporanee e quello che succede
quando olre alla conservazione del senso
si crea nuovo senso e i padroni
dell'aria questo lo fanno se sono dei
veri padroni dell'aria lo fanno altre
due caratteristi che sono due fac della
stessa medaglia dei padroni dell'aria
sono la capacità di retrospezione e di
prospettiva
retrospezione in quanto cura di ciò che
è avvenuto sanno sempre guardarsi alle
spalle guardare dietro senza mai essere
prigionieri del passato senza mai essere
troppo troppo succubi della memoria ma
curatori delle memorie quindi
retrospezione nella capacità di
creazione di senso la retrospezione è
fondamentale non la storia non inizia
dal momento in cui operiamo noi dobbiamo
sempre tener presente quello che
successo prima l'altra faccia di questa
medaglia è la è la prospettiva il
padrone dell'aria ha retrospettiva e
prospettiva riesce a guardare avanti
grazie alla sua capacità di
retrospezione riesce ad avere una
visione riesce a costruirla quella
visione proprio grazie alla memoria che
che conserva proprio grazie al fatto che
è proteso in
avanti l'innesto ne è una prova si
innesta perché si crede nel futuro di
una pianta che è già lì che ha una
storia in retrospezione e
nell'innesto una prospettiva
nuova creare una prospettiva vuol dire
anche interpretare un po' la luce e la
luce mi piace abbinarla ai padroni
dell'aria Perché l'aria e la luce sono
due elementi Vitali per noi che non
tocchiamo Ma che dobbiamo interpretare e
in
modo ingannevole per noi e anche
piacevol ingannevole dobbiamo dominarli
dobbiamo esserne
padroni altrimenti non riusciamo a
creare e quindi a creare
senso ultima caratteristica dei padroni
dell'aria è la capacità di narrare e di
ricreare allo stesso tempo quindi
raccontare storie ma non finalizzate
alle storie finalizzate al fatto che
devono ispirare gli altri devono
ricreare narrare per ricreare non si
racconta tanto per si racconta per
stimolare si racconta per accendere un
fuoco ci sono gesti parole suoni che
stimolano gli altri non sono una
performance fino a se stessa sono una
performance che deve
innescare
nuove nuovi fuochi deve accendere nuovi
fuochi grazie alle scintille del
racconto in un mondo che cambia in un
mondo complesso in un mondo dove
dobbiamo abbiamo il dovere di stimolare
nuovi artigiani nuovi imprenditori
imprenditrici amministratori
locali Policy
Maker
designer
commercianti abbiamo anche la necessità
e il dovere di stimolarli in quanto
padroni dell'aria non solo in quanto
persone competenti ma in quanto leader
carismatici narratori di luoghi che
grazie alla loro presenza
diventano unici diventano unici proprio
perché in una complessità carica di
senso e
quindi quello che lascio è questo invito
quello di cercare e di stimolare la
nascita di padroni dell'aria che lascino
un segno con la loro opera col loro
lavoro che lascino un segno che possa
rinar rare ricreare il mondo ogni giorno
in modo ciclico
in questo gioco infinito chiamato vita
[Applauso]
[Musica]
grazie